la gripe sin ya como definió ya ir
bolsonaro alcoy 19 vuelve a propinarle
un revés la enfermedad cobró la vida de
tres mil 251 personas en las últimas 24
horas provocando que varias ciudades se
unieron en un sonoro y masivo cacerolazo
para rechazar el manejo que el jefe de
estado le ha dado la pandemia esto
mientras el mandatario intentaba dar un
mensaje de tranquilidad en su discurso
televisivo
el virus llegó y está siendo enfrentado
por nosotros y pronto pasará y pasará de
nuestra vida debe continuar nuestros
empleos deben mantener sus usted los
sustentos de las familias deben ser
protegidos deberíamos volver a la
normalidad normalidad personal o dijo
que 2021 sería el año de la vacunación
sin embargo este ha sido un proceso
lento y hasta la fecha menos de un 8% de
la población ha recibido la primera
dosis la noticia coincidió con la
juramentación a puerta cerrada del
cuarto ministro de salud en un año el
cardiólogo marcelo quiroga quien llega
para reemplazar al general del ejército
para suelo adicionalmente el magistrado
marco aurelio mello integrante de la
corte suprema rechazó la petición de
bolsonaro para impedir que los gobiernos
municipales dicten medidas restrictivas
sobre la población como parte de sus
esfuerzos para disminuir los contagios
a juicio del magistrado la petición
presentó un error y es que fue firmada
por el propio bolsonaro en lugar de la
procuraduría de la nación el artículo
103 inciso 1º de la constitución federal
es pedagógica en cuanto a que prevé la
legitimidad del presidente de la
republica para proponer una acción
directa de inconstitucionalidad siendo
impropio confundir la con la capacidad
postula toria brasil el país más
golpeado de américa latina' registra más
de 12 millones de contagios confirmados
y se acerca al umbral de las 300.000
muertes